[Music]
all right
i uh i'm john harmon uh i'm a senior
data scientist at macmillan learning and
today i'm going to
talk to you about uh mentoring at the
r4ds online learning community
all right so uh the takeaways i want you
to get from this talk
are that teaching is a good way to
increase your fluency
and that i need 40 of you to go to
r4ds.online
click slack and message me john the geek
so r4ds online learning community was
founded in 2017 by
jesse mastapak it started as
a study group for going through the
art for data science book by hadley and
garrett grillman
and it's kind of evolved into just a
place you can come
with when you're struggling with
something in our and someone will help
you
figure out how to do that thing you can
find us
at r4ds.online click slack
we have over 4000 members about 250 of
which are active every week and uh we're
most famous for the tidy tuesday project
on twitter
where every monday we release a data set
and then people create visualizations
and
post their visualizations in their code
on
on twitter we also do the r feedback
friday hashtag
and the function friday um
just as a way to engage with the our
stats community on twitter
but what we what i'm focusing focusing
on today
is we also do office hours uh every
saturday
i am on our slack from uh starting at 11
am
central time 9 am pacific
and just when questions come in i i help
people find the answers now usually
it's something like hey is there a
function to do this
and i know what function it is or i can
go look up what function it is
um but uh sometimes it'll be something
that i have no idea
but i have more experience using r and i
know how to read help
and i know how to google and so usually
i'm guiding people through
how to do that um my goal
why i said i need 40 people is i want to
have 40 people doing this we've got
uh i think we're up to eight now um
i want to have a full-time tutor by this
time next year
equivalent so 40 hours a week more than
that would be great
um so i would like you to go to
r4ds.online
click slack and message john the geek
some examples of why you should do this
number one
teaching is a great way to learn
when you teach something you have to
understand it
uh and so it helps you develop more
proficiency
there's some references on that in the
learning by teaching article on
wikipedia i don't have time to go
through all of that
but it's there um some examples
over on the left was just last week
someone was asking about how to learn to
do presentations
with rmd and
this was really helpful to me not quite
timely enough because if you look at my
slides this is
in google slides but soon now i have
the info that i know where to go to
learn
uh how to uh make these presentations
uh in in r uh another example was when
tune
from tidy models first came out on
github a bunch of us were playing with
that
and someone was like hey this uh example
code in the vignette doesn't work
and so i was like oh let me look and oh
it didn't work for me either
so i uh ended up creating an issue
um worked through that with max and then
i also did
a pull request for some documentation so
i ended up
i'm a contributor to tune now because of
r4ds
and also i learned a lot about how tune
works by going through trying to figure
out why it didn't work and then
realizing oh because it's broken
so if you want to see more examples you
can go to r4ds.online
uh you can click slack and hopefully
message me john thegeek and sign up for
an hour a week
an hour every other week an hour a month
whatever you can do
it's it's just it's a lot of fun and
it's a great way to develop your skills
and that's my time thank you